good afternoon everyone and welcome
today's talk will feature a conversation
between secretary golf Cruise and Susan
Cain followed by a question-and-answer
session when you came in you should have
received a note card and pencil if you
haven't and are interested in submitting
a question please raise your hand and
let an usher know feel free to write
down questions in the first half of this
event and pass them to the aisles so the
ushers can grab them so that we can
answer some of those questions later on
in the event it is now my pleasure to
introduce secretary and vice president
for student life
Kimberly Gulf Cruise Secretary Gulf
Cruise is a graduate of Yale College and
Yale Law School after several years in
private law practice Misgav Cruz
returned to Yale as assistant dean in
Yale College and director of the
afro-american cultural center she then
went on to serve in various roles at
Wellesley University Wellesley College
and the University of Chicago in 2012
she returned to Yale as secretary and
vice president for student life as she
supports institutional governance
oversees official university functions
and provides strategic direction to
improve the student experience her goal
is to help keep Yale at the forefront of
education it is my pleasure to introduce
secretary goth Cruz
so it's great to see all of you in the
audience today and welcome our guest
Susan Cain who just drove in from the
Hudson River Valley so we're really
grateful for your your travel here this
event just so you know is part of the
vulnerability and leadership series
where we invite leaders from all sectors
of society to talk about leadership
aspect of leadership self development
resiliency and obviously vulnerability
the series is co-sponsored by the Yale
well initiative which was formerly
called the wellness project and that
initiative was created in response to
your request students requests to have
resources training and conversations
about what it means to be a whole human
being not just the person who's studying
but someone who's doing all the other
things that you do and how to do that
well today's conversation is going to
focus on the ways in which introverts
can thrive in communities like Yale and
Beyond it and how introverts can
participate in the classroom in the lab
and the studio how they can run student
organizations how they can have
successful jobs and lives our
conversation is for those of you who are
introverts both of us are introverts
it's for extroverts and all of people
who work with them so it's for students
faculty and staff and we're honored to
have Susan Cain who was dubbed the fairy
godmother of introvert she is the New
York Times bestselling author of quiet
the power of introverts in a world that
can't stop talking and she has a record
smashing TED talk that has been viewed
17 million times so she I think you're
in the top 20 at this point her second
book is called quiet power the secret
strength of introverts and it's adapted
from our first book but it does focus on
kids and teenagers and how they can
thrive as introverts in school and
extracurricular activities family life
and friendships she is the leader of a
revolution the co-founder of the quiet
revolution in facts
the quiet schools Network and the quiet
Leadership Institute she has been
writing and her writings can be seen in
the New York Times the Atlantic The Wall
Street Journal and she has numerous
awards she graduate from Princeton
that's the only downside Harvard Law
School
but she does live as I said in the
Hudson River Valley with her husband and
her two sons so we are delighted that
she made the trip to join us to talk
about introverts and how best is thrive
welcome so I thought we would start with
a conversation about what exactly is an
introvert and I've been reading your
Twitter feet which you have phenomenal
things coming out almost every day and a
couple days ago you had an ad from the
risk whiskey River River soap company
that makes soap and has irreverent
labels and they make soap for foodies
for you know cool kids and they happen
to make a soap for introverts and here's
what they said
people suck that's why you prefer you
introverts prefer to stay inside with
your stuffed animal collection but even
enjoying your own company requires some
ambience and some basic hygiene so wash
up with soap for introverts a
handcrafted bar dyed with a blend of
non-confrontational ocean blues and we
didn't bother sending it because
seriously it's not like you're gonna go
anywhere so that's the so that's some
people's view of what it means to be an
introvert but is that actually true what
is your definition of an introvert yeah
you know and it's funny that we're
starting with that but wait first of all
I just want to say hi to all of you it's
so nice to be here and notwithstanding
your quip about Princeton I really love
Yale as everyone who knows me knows my
sister went here and was in Saybrook
college and I've just always loved this
place so thank you for having me
so I actually had great mixed feelings
about posting that so bad especially
because of what you began with the idea
that people suck which i think is
actually the great myth of what
introverts are you know people who think
that other people suck and I don't think
that's true at all we actually know you
know if you look at personality
psychology there's no correlation
between introversion extroversion versus
how warm and loving
or agreeable you are that those two
things are distinct so it's more that
introverts like to socialize in a very
different way preferring to focus their
energies on one or two people at a time
and to really go deep socially but like
really the definition is more about
what's happening neurobiologically
because introverts have nervous systems
that just react more to stimulation
Alki it could be social stimulation but
it could also be lights and noise and
just stuff going on in your lives and if
you're someone who reacts more to
stimulation that means that you feel at
your most alive and calm when you're in
quieter settings and you feel a little
bit jangled when when things ramp up a
lot but I do think that what happens is
we all from such an early age are taught
to adapt to a more extroverted culture
that we lose sight of how we actually
prefer to spend our own time so I think
if you wanted to figure out in two
seconds where you fit on this introvert
extrovert spectrum the real question to
ask yourself is imagine that you have a
weekend or maybe even a week to spend
exactly as you please with zero social
or academic or whatever obligations how
would you spend that time and how many
people would you spend it with if you're
really giving yourself that permission
and I think that gives you your true
north and you talked a little bit about
the fact that the the culture around the
u.s. culture I think about how people
think about introversion has shifted
over time can you say a little bit more
about that oh yeah yes I was really
curious when I first started researching
this book whether this cultural bias
that I had you know knew we were all
living with and whether it whether it
was something that was intrinsic and
innate to any culture so I thought okay
well the first thing to do is look at
has u.s. culture always been this way
and our cultures across the world this
way or we you know is this kind of the
way it has to be so when I looked at the
US what I found is that cultural
historians
we used to live in a culture of
character this was back in the 19th
century and this was a time when people
were living in smaller towns alongside
people they had known all their lives
so the qualities that mattered were kind
of more inward and deep qualities like
do you have character and do you take
care of the people around you you know
because you get to know over time which
neighbors do and which ones don't but
then in the 20th century with the rise
of cities and industrialization we all
started moving into these great
population centers where you're living
now alongside strangers and you're
working in corporations often and what
started to matter was these qualities of
do you have magnetism and you know can
you dazzle somebody the minute you meet
them as opposed to what unfolds over the
course of your life together and so
that's when we moved into this culture
of personality and do you see a
difference in terms of how introversion
plays out for women and men and how
people value introversion and women and
men that's an interesting question
because the the the number of female and
male introverts is the same I mean
according to recent studies it's about
50% for each for each how about you
actually do you think exist I mean is
there is it half the population where
interprets or how many times what the
most recent studies show and then older
study is found about a third were
introverts so I figure either way you
know we're talking one out of every two
or three people okay so you're saying a
third to a half for introverts yes
and then of that it's mostly it's half
and half of that there's no difference
really for male or female but I think
what is different is just the way it
plays out he's done social expectations
right because for women you know it's
both easier and harder at the same time
for women I think there is more cultural
license to be just quiet and hanging
back and I get you know that that
derives from all kinds of problematic
right constraints that women have been
operating under but in this one case it
gives you a little more latitude on the
other hand women have historically been
expected to play the role of the
vivacious host person right
and then for men you know male
introverts do automatically have the
authority that is accorded to males in
agriculture but at the same time the
pressure for male introverts is the the
pressure to be kind of the dominant and
take-charge person and like these are
obviously stereotypes that may play out
in all different ways but these are some
of the kind of trends that I hear about
from people and do there are there other
cultures across the world that value
introversion differently we found that
were more positive in terms of how they
thought about introverts yeah yeah so I
mean the ones that spring to mind the
quickest it kind of varies from culture
to culture Finland is is known to be a
much quieter society and then I actually
spent a whole chapter of the book
looking at Confucian based societies
which I mean it's really interesting
there because you know there's there's
much more of sorry I've got like here
and my coming out of my microphone you
have in Confucian based societies much
more of the idea of group orientation
and that no one person should stand out
too much from the group and so it's
better to be quieter and there's a sense
of strength being found in silence so
like I always think of this one I did a
ton of interviews for this chapter and
there's one I always think of from a
woman I met who have come to this
country from Shanghai and she was
biologically I would say one of the more
extroverted people I've ever met you
know she was just like this very jolly
outgoing person by nature but she talked
about how when she first came here and
she was in school I think it may have
been grad school at the time she was
absolutely shocked to find these
cultural norms where you know the way
she put it was like the students are
expected to talk nonsense
raise your hand and talk nonsense and
then the teachers nod respectfully at
you and encourage you to speak more
nonsense and you know and from her point
of view that's like wasting everybody's
time why would you ever do that right so
yeah so let's move to the classroom why
don't we and talk about introverts in
the classroom and what
what how they might thrive in mushroom I
remember in your book I think it was in
the secret the second book there was a
cartoon of a student who has a bubble
saying don't call him me don't call me
don't call him me I don't know about if
you have had those that kind of
experience like please don't call me
could you talk a little bit about the
the kind of things you think worked for
for for an interpreted student yeah well
I'll give you one tip and and you'll
you'll get this as a fellow law person I
discovered this kind of accidentally
when I was in law school and you know
you in law school classes are conducted
in these giant amphitheaters with a
Socratic method and the professor just
calls on you in front of hundreds of
people and I really wanted when I first
got there I really wanted to avoid just
being called on and in that kind of a
way so I forced myself like on the first
or second day of class she raised my
hand and just say something anything
because I reasons that then the
professor would be less likely to
cold-call me and and not only did it
work in terms of avoiding the cold
calling but I found it had this other
incredible unexpected by-product which
was that after that the professor
started directing comments to me and
would refer back to things I had said
early on and I feel about that I
actually really liked it you know I felt
like oh I contributed something to this
class and and that felt really good
you know and other students after class
would we'd be talking about class and
they would refer to to that kind of
thing so I discovered through this and
now I work with a lot of people in
workplaces and I often advise them in
meetings to do the same thing of
thinking in advance something you might
want to contribute or a question you
want to raise and giving yourself a push
to ask it early because what happens
then is that you emotionally when you do
that become a center in the room and
other people are directing energy
towards you and if you wait too long to
speak you feel emotionally ever further
to the margins and it becomes harder and
harder to feel like you actually have a
place there so those kinds of subtle
shifts make a really big difference now
if you're a back
team member or you're running a meeting
perhaps and you recognize that something
might be interpreted what would you say
we should do in that situation well I
mean a few things what one is especially
if there's an area where you know that
that person might have a lot to
contribute you might want to let them
know in advance you know we're gonna be
talking about XYZ today and I would love
to hear your thoughts on this because I
know you've got a lot to say or you
could use other techniques like going
around the room and having everybody
contribute because a lot of what we're
talking about whether it's biological
introversion or cultural introversion or
gender you know all these different
things are at play some people feel like
they have a lot more permission to speak
than others do just on some deep down
level and so you want to create
structures where the people who feel
they have less permission or handed the
permission and invited to speak and and
so another thing you could do is say
okay we've got everybody seems to be
going in the direction of opinion X can
we have somebody take the devil's
advocate position of opinion Y and I
just want you to argue that position and
then you're giving someone that the
permission to go against the grain
without necessarily having to own it at
that moment but they're just invited to
take that rule so it sounds like you're
talking about a difference between or
you see a difference between class
participation in class engagement is
that what I'm hearing well I don't know
I mean all those things I think have
more to do with participation in a way
class engagement I think is it's an
important thing to think about because I
think we do tend to think too much that
class participation means you know going
like this or speaking out and in fact
for a lot of people they're engaging
deeply with a material by reading and
taking notes about it or you know by
talking with a classmate after class and
for them that engagement is just as
profound even though it's harder to
track from the professor's point of view
you use this interesting phrase called
passing as an extrovert yeah just a
barrier you know I don't know if
anybody's felt that but can you talk
about that phenomena and give us some
examples of what that might look like
yeah I mean
I heard about this for people all the
time I okay so I first became a well no
I guess I've always known this but I
became aware of the extent of this
phenomenon of basically introverts
pretending to be more extroverted than
they really were my book came out and
then I gave a TED talk about it just a
few weeks later and the audience at Ted
you know it's I don't know how many
people fifteen hundred or something and
and it's this audience of these huge
movers and shakers and I came off the
stage and and I was one of the first
speakers and then I was there all week
and for the whole rest of that week I
literally I I could barely even walk an
inch across the room because everybody
was coming up to me and telling me
that's my story too and don't tell as
some would literally say don't tell
anyone but that's who I really am or
someone say you know I've never told
anyone before but now I'm going to and
and this has kept happening to me so I I
did I sat once on a panel and the other
panelists were it was Arianna Huffington
George Stephanopoulos Candice Bergen and
I'm forgetting some of the others but
they were anchor people on TV and one by
one they all said yeah I'm an introvert
I'm an introvert I'm an introvert and
it's just like the extent to which
people don't talk about how they really
feel and what their true social
preferences are it's it's it's so
enormous that I can't even put it into
words is this why you created the
Lacroix revolution found eight or your
Institute rather yeah in Harlem it's can
you talk a little bit more about that
what you hope to accomplish and why did
you start on just work and school I mean
really it's as you said you have to
narrow it anyone's work in those two
areas yeah I mean well focus is on work
in school because I think those are the
places where people spend the most of
their time right you know kids are there
all day grown-ups or at work all day and
and these are the social structures that
I think have the most profound impact on
our lives sure we have a number of
students here who are student leaders so
switch a little bit so how how you think
of a quiet leader and
in a way that might be supportive for
student organizations here can you talk
about what you see is effective quiet
leadership yeah I mean it looks it it
looks like so many different things but
I'm gonna start actually by giving you a
statistic I think and there's a lot of
these statistics now but I I do believe
that when most people think of what a
good leader is or a natural leader is
they're assuming whether consciously or
not they're assuming that it's somebody
very charismatic and outspoken and type
a you know all that and in fact there
was this one study where a guy named Jim
Collins went out and and looked at the
the 11 best performing companies in the
country and he wanted to figure out what
set these companies apart from the rest
of the more mediocre pack and he found
that every single one of these companies
was led by a CEO who had two
characteristics the first one was having
a fierce sense of will and dedication
like they really cared about the company
and then the second characteristic was
that these each of these CEOs was
described by their peers as being quiet
unassuming low-key soft-spoken and even
shy and you know that not what we would
normally think it's not what you would
normally think and it might at first
seem so counterintuitive you'd be like
how can what can explain this but if you
study introverts the way I do it's not
that surprising because what happens is
and for those of you who are introverts
you know this we tend to get really
passionate about one or two areas in our
lives and to like really go deep into
those passions and so in the service of
your passions you will end up acquiring
all kinds of expertise and building your
networks as you get to know other people
who have the same passion and you start
inspiring trust in people so you start
seeing all these leaders who ascend to
these roles not because they were the
kinds of kids who just like had a will
to leave because some children are like
that
you know and they're like that all their
lives so they're not those people they
just like really care about this thing
and in the name of this thing they
become a great leader and and all of
these CEOs were like that and and
there's so many I mean so Gandhi there's
another great example who Gandhi was so
shy when he was a kid at school he used
to run home from school as soon as the
bell rang because he didn't want to have
to socialize with his classmates and if
you look at his autobiography he talks
about for all his life being really
uncomfortable in group settings and not
liking to be the one running meetings or
holding forth and those qualities of
effortlessly you know bringing together
a group it is an amazing asset to
leadership I don't want to pretend that
it's not what I do want to say is that
there are so many different pathways to
fulfilling these roles and somebody like
a Gandhi who just cared so deeply and
everybody knew it ends up attracting the
other people who care about that same
thing with the same authentic depth and
you end up building a movement that way
mm-hmm so so that's what leader quiet
leadership often looks like you know it
looks like like a really deep commitment
and you talk also about the fact that
quiet leaders often have a partner who
offsets yeah or complements part of what
can you talk a little about that and
give us some examples yeah absolutely I
mean so i think this is true for all
areas of life that you know no one human
being is good at everything and so the
more honest you can be with yourself
about what your strengths are and what
your gaps are the more you can surround
yourself with people who you love who
also offset those gaps so for example at
Facebook share a Mark Zuckerberg CEO
he's a very introverted guy everybody
says and he brought Sheryl Sandberg in
as his CEO Oh partly cuz you know she's
super talented and also because she's a
very strong extrovert and so for her
it's very natural and she likes to spend
time building relationships with
advertisers and that kind of thing and
he likes to spend time poring over
analysis and that kind of thing not to
say each one can't do the other and it's
not to say each one doesn't sometimes
have to stretch outside their comfort
zone to do the other but you're so much
more effective if you can just have
someone else doing that so it like to me
yin and yang is the answer to everything
in all ways you know let me go back to
the question of definitions because I'm
not sure I really understand the
difference between being an introvert
being quiet and being shy yeah I think
there's a range but I'm not coach can
you talk about that's a really good
question because introversion is much
more about how you react to stimulation
so you know you just kind of prefer
settings where there's less stuff coming
at you and shyness is more about the
fear of social judgment so if you're a
shy person and let's say you're looking
at someone's face and they have a
neutral expression on their face you
will tend to read disapproval into the
neutral expression and that disapproval
will wound you more than it would for a
less shy person and this tends to come
out in especially in settings where
social judgment is woven into the
experience like a job interview or going
on a date or public speaking or
something like that so in terms of the
work that we've been doing it quite
revolution and in my book and so on
we're really looking at both it's about
introversion and about shyness but
important to know that it's not a
complete overlap so you could be an
introvert who's not shy at all and I
believe President Obama is probably an
example of this I think he's quite
introverted and really not anxious in
any way socially or otherwise and then
you can be a shy extrovert like the
singer Barbara Streisand
who everyone says has a very
larger-than-life personality but she
stopped performing for decades because
her stage fright was so intense so these
things are pretty complicated let's go
back to now talking about students and
I'm thinking about social environment
and social things like parties and
networking and all those kind of things
and that can be really difficult for
some
whose introverted can you talk a little
bit about how we might navigate that
successfully and so one on the one hand
and then how if you're if you're hosting
a party or in social networking event
how you might organize that so that it
makes it easier for people to function
yeah well I mean the first thing I would
go back to is the idea of constantly
asking yourself like if I truly were
spending my time the way I prefer to
spend it what would I be doing right now
because you know you you all are living
at a stage of your life lives where
there's tremendous pressure to be going
to parties all the time and maybe you
enjoy that and maybe you don't and if
you don't it's okay I mean especially on
a campus like this there's a thousand
ways of connecting with people and
getting to know your classmates that
don't involve going to a big keg party
or whatever it is so like do it some of
the time but you probably don't have to
go as much as you're thinking that you
do number one and I would look for the
alternative ways like maybe you'd rather
get together in a small group with other
people who share the same interest and
and connect that way but when you are
going to parties and especially if
you're having those moments of
discomfort what can really there's two
mental tricks that help one is to think
of yourself as the host and make it your
role to make the people around you feel
comfortable so that you start taking
your mental energy away from your own
discomfort and towards everyone else's
and you can assume that at least half
the people there have way more
discomfort than they're trying to
express and then the other thing is to
make it a kind of intellectual puzzle of
just knowing I mean you know this
everybody has something absolutely
fascinating about them and so if you're
a job when you're meeting somebody is to
figure out like to tap into your
curiosity and figure out what is the
thing that's really fascinating here
that can make it really interesting and
you might develop real connections that
way right I want to go a little bit back
to leadership because you now are
running this organization
and you're still writing I wonder if you
could talk about vulnerability and
leadership which is the theme of our of
our series in what ways have you seen
yourself be vulnerable as a leader and
how have you adapted to that oh yeah I
mean I think it's at the core of
everything really
and I you know I think you would ask me
the question of like is it easier to be
vulnerable on the page or in real life
and it's much easier to be vulnerable on
the page I believe I think you don't
have to look at the people who are
reading about your vulnerable thing as
you're talking about it but it's really
complicated we were living in this world
where although it's now become
fashionable to talk about words like
vulnerability let me say it differently
I think there is a balance that we're
all constantly striking between having
to think about self presentation which
is a fact of life and having to think
about being really or not think about it
but wanting to be really sincere with
the people around you and you can't be
sincere without being vulnerable it's
impossible because every single one of
you has some kind of deep ache at the
center of your being because you're
human I mean there's whether you're
religious or not every single religious
tradition is premised on this idea you
know Adam and Eve thrown out of the
Garden of Eden the gardens gone you know
Buddha leaves his father's Palace and
discovers that actually life is
dissatisfaction and suffering and and
then figures out what to do about it
this is a human truth and it's it's so
weird to me that we live with us human
truth and yet we're usually not allowed
to talk about it most of the time and so
like all this talk about you know going
on Facebook and and people will say well
it it can be very fake and overly
curated and I think that what people are
really reacting to is not so much the
status anxiety that Facebook and juices
and people but it's just really grating
that people that no one's telling the
truth I think we all want the truth
so in this example when you've been
vulnerable on how that has how you dealt
with it yeah okay
yeah show me but I I think one of there
are a few reasons but one of the reasons
it took me a while to become a writer
even though that was what I had always
wanted to do is that I liked writing
about the vulnerable stuff I liked
writing about like telling the truth
about what it's like to be alive and the
hard things and so it was really
uncomfortable for me and embarrassing at
the beginning to write a book about
being an introvert you know and during
the like now okay now everybody is
talking about it a little bit more so
it's okay but during the years that I
was writing the book and it hadn't come
in - yes at what seven years I think you
said yeah yeah I was I was working on it
for seven years and I remember going to
dinner parties and saying yeah I'm
writing this book about introversion and
people would be like what you know like
it seems like a weird topic at the time
and it felt like a stigmatized topic so
I just had to finally decide okay I'm
just gonna deal with that and that's the
price that I'm gonna pay in order to
tell the truth about what I think so
that your writing was your act of
vulnerability and okay yeah so first the
writing was then once I had the book
contract and I was working on the book I
was like okay I'm okay with that but now
I have to go up on stage and talk about
it you know and that was a whole other
thing that was way harder at the
beginning now I'm really used to it but
I walked around for the first few months
after the book was published and doing
all the publicity stuff that you have to
do you know I I just felt incredibly raw
and exposed and but I will say the good
news is you get over those feelings like
the more you get over them well it's
just the more you're exposed to things
that are uncomfortable the more you
become desensitized to them like people
have studied this phenomenon so and the
key for anything that you're feeling
uncomfortable about whether it's sort of
generic public speaking or about being
specifically vulnerable the key is to
expose yourself to the thing that's
making you so uncomfortable in very
small and bite-sized ways
so like for me I actually went to a
class for people who were uncomfortable
with public speaking and the very first
session of the class but all we had to
do was stand up say our names and sit
back down again and declare victory you
know and then you'd go back the next
week and and all you'd have to do is
stand up and answer a few questions
about yourself like where you'd been to
school and where you grew up to clear
victory sit back down and you kind of
ratcheted it up a little by little from
there and the miracle of it is that that
process just somehow works and it it can
really all melt away you know there was
a New York Times op-ed that you did I
think it was in March of this year and
it's it's the corollaries different
conversation about leaders were talking
about followers and I wanted to read to
you what a little bit about what you
wrote just ask you about it because it's
in a way you argued that college
campuses need to really create more
followers not leaders that was sort of a
theme I believe of the op-eds aid if
college admissions offices show us whom
and what we value then we seem to think
that the ideal Society is composed of
type A's
this is perhaps so unsurprising even if
these examples come from highly
competitive institutions it's part of
the American DNA to celebrate those who
rise above the crowd and in recent
decades the meteoric path to leadership
of youthful of youthful garage and dorm
dwellers from Steve Jobs to Mark
Zuckerberg has made king of the hill
status seem possible for every 19-year
old so now we have high school students
buying to be presidents of as many clubs
as they can it's no longer enough to be
a member of the student council now you
have to run the school get a
well-functioning student body
not to mention polity also needs
followers it needs team players and it
needs those who go their own way it
needs it needs leaders who are called to
service rather than to status that's a
pretty powerful statement so could you
talk a little bit more about that and
yeah I mean ok so I was horrified by
this even back when I was applying to
schools and even more horrified now by
the pressure that all of you are under
from a very young age
you had to have felt it to get here the
the pressure to be the leader of this
and to be the leader of that and I'm as
you can tell from what I said before I'm
all for being the leader of something
that you truly care about like you
should do that but it just it seems to
me that in the culture now there's this
there's a kind of emptiness in the
pressure to just be the leader of
something for its own sake and and I
believe that you can have a life full of
great contribution to the people around
you and full of great personal happiness
and fulfilling without being the leader
of a damn thing you know you could go
and do great science or a great art or
be a great parent or you know in any
number of things that have nothing to do
with conventional notions of leadership
so yeah what's been the response to that
statement an enormous amount of interest
actually yeah I mean I I heard from a
lot of universities who were interested
in this topic
yeah in fairness to university
admissions I think that most admissions
offices know that this is a problem and
at the same time they're inundated with
all these applications and how on earth
do you distinguish one from another but
I just wish we could expand the way we
think about what it means to be human
yeah one of the things you talk about is
the importance of space I think it call
them nurturing niche nice I think it's
definitely to call but you know we're
sort of thinking we sort of niches and
we are we are building we've just built
two new colleges two new residential
colleges we've we are building a new
Campus Center where we are always
looking for space on campus and yeah you
talked about the need for introverts to
be in not just large spaces like this
but small spaces and and also what it's
like to be in a dorm space and how to
function if you're in those small spaces
yeah you talked a little bit and gives
people advice about how they might
navigate that and how we might actually
want think about building our buildings
oh yeah yeah I mean so what I'm about to
say it's true for everyone it's kind of
more true for introverts but really all
he
need to be in physical spaces where you
have spaces to come together and you
also have spaces that you can come right
where you can be by yourself so you know
I don't know how much you guys have been
exposed to it but in corporate America
now are really globally the trend in
office design it's these gigantic open
plan offices where people don't really
get that much personal space and when I
was first researching my book and I
started talking to people in these
offices they were all coming up to me
and kind of whispering and saying you
know I I'm really unhappy in this office
but I can't I can't say this to my boss
because I'll be perceived as not being a
team player and they would say is there
any research out there that I could show
my boss to just prove to them why they
shouldn't be designing the next space
that we're moving to you like that and I
started looking and I found that there's
this mountain of data that's out there
and again this data is not even about
introverts it's just about humans that
like if you're in a space where you have
no privacy and you feel like you're
subject to people's gaze and people's
evaluation all the time it it increases
pressure it increases cognitive load you
get interrupted more so it takes you
more time to do things and you get sick
more often and then the weird real
paradox is you actually don't form as
many social bonds or close ones because
if you think about it the the currency
of forming a true friendship is often
that you're sharing information with
your friends that you wouldn't be
sharing to everybody in your dorm or
office and if you can never be alone in
order to do that that's just not going
to be happening as often so in terms of
how to build university spaces my
suggestion is to design them so that
you've got the open spaces here but
you've got plenty of nooks and crannies
where people can go to be by themselves
or to be little dyads
you know and I'll tell you I remember
this even from when I was an undergrad
at Princeton and the dining hall that I
went to you in my residential college it
was a modern one
and it was designed so that it had all
the big tables were in the center and
then you had a few tables that were
meant for just two or three or two or
three people at a time and the they were
off on the sides but in kind of in the
cobwebby sides you felt like those were
the dusty undesirable tables at which to
sit and I remember even then feeling
this conflict and feeling like gosh I'd
really rather be sitting at one of those
tables with one or two friends having a
real conversation but there was so much
social pressure that was built right
into the design to be sitting at the big
tables where people were recounting
their drinking games from the weekend
before and and and yeah so the physical
space really makes a difference business
yeah well you've given us a lot to think
about so we have questions from the
audience I'm going to turn our attention
to those and our first question is what
advice can you give to introverts who
want to stand out and take leadership
positions but sometimes feel
overshadowed by the extroverted peers
yeah I mean the best thing that you can
do really well it's a couple things one
is to develop mastery and expertise in
whatever the area is where you want to
be a leader because first of all the
more mastery you have the more
confidence you're gonna have and you're
gonna be expressing that confidence in
all kinds of ways you're not even aware
of and other people will be reacting to
it too so it will all just kind of
happen more naturally and and then the
other thing is to come back to what we
said before of just give yourself pushes
if it's something that really matters to
you give yourself a push to speak at the
moments that you might be kind of afraid
to do it or do in the beginning or end
do it beginning yeah yeah one rule of
thumb that I often give to people is to
ask yourself am I not speaking or am I
not doing X Y Z out of fear or just out
of true preference and if it's out of
fear don't don't let the fear be your
master you know
blow past the fear but if it's out of a
true preference if this is actually what
I'd rather be doing then honor that our
next question is how does introversion
change introversion change over the
course of a lifetime
or through different stages of life yes
so this is complicated because the data
shows that for all of us over time we
get more introverted really yeah yeah I
mean haven't you noticed that I feel
like I have with my friends that I'm
selective I'm sorry I'm more selective
okay but oh yeah okay so so people
mellow out I think it's probably because
their nervous systems all of them become
more reactive to stimulation as you get
older so people see quiet more but on
the other hand what happens is we all
develop so many skills as we grow older
that things that would have for
introverts let's say things that would
have bothered us when we were younger
may become less of a big deal as we get
older you know such as public speaking
like if you have a fear of that for
example you might really overcome it and
so you're gonna start seaming and acting
like more of an extrovert as you grow
older and get those skills but your
underlying being probably won't change
and might even get quieter okay we
talked a little bit about spaces and I'm
going to come back to in a second but
the question now is how do you make time
to be alone or recharge when you live in
a university environment yeah I'm all
dorm rooms I think is what the yeah so
if you're living in this kind of an
environment you have to really
prioritize it and that is the only way
it's gonna happen you have to make it a
commitment that you honor as fiercely as
the commitment to study for your
midterms
what does that look like what is that
what does it look like I don't know I
mean and for you it might be taking a
walk like just taking a walk around this
campus there's people all around you but
you can walk quite undisturbed I think
I'm sure there are some pathways where
you can for some people it's gonna be
exercise you have to kind of figure out
what your thing is but in my experience
the hurdle is not so much figuring out
the space as it is feeling
emotionally entitled to actually do it
because what you're gonna be feeling is
like I shouldn't be doing this there's
something wrong with my need to do it
I'm too busy to do it but you just have
to tell yourself you're gonna be so much
more socially present and academically
on your game if you give yourself those
moments then if you don't how can we
help as administrators and faculty in
getting that message out what would you
suggest that we do I would well first of
all I would talk about it I mean I a lot
of the issue here is just kind of
normalizing this discourse and making it
part of everyday a conversation I would
asked for people who you think are
influential role models on campus
whether they're professors or students
or whatever who are introverts to have
discussions like this one where they
talk about what their strengths are as
introverts what their challenges have
been so it just becomes part of the
everyday language and when you're when
you're creating programs like an
orientation program let's say you make
sure to build in quiet space and breaks
for people and have the people who are
leaving the programs honor not just
honored it like oh we we know you can
traverse need it but just like you know
more like everybody needs this kind of
way so now it's time now we're gonna
have our quiet space because we all need
that you know call it meditation if you
need to cuz that's a fashion for you to
learn it yeah okay should we categorize
introverts and extroverts or think of
introversion as a spectrum oh thank you
for asking that whoever that came from
we should think of it as a spectrum for
sure so Carl Jung the psychologist who
first popularized these terms in the
1920s even he said no such thing as pure
introvert or pure extrovert
he said such a man would be an Aluna
tick asylum that was his quote and so we
all have a tendency to be one part of
the spectrum or another but we're also
all much more complex than that and I'm
sure you've had the experience if you're
extroverts of feeling like oh now I'm
really seeking quiet time or if you're
introverts feeling like
oh my gosh you know when I'm around
these people I'm talking about this
subject I feel like really out there so
that's that's all part of it so I know
that you you some people have said that
you are so focused on introverts that
you must be anti extrovert but I don't
think that that's true yeah I know
you're having you married to an
introvert
yeah and I'd like to actually ask you to
talk to the extroverts in the room about
what you know you know what they can do
to support the introverts in their myths
yeah like if I asked your husband what
he does for you what would he say oh
gosh well it's also what I do for him
because it's both like we actually both
need to make all kinds of adjustments so
I think for my husband it would be it's
probably things like you know the advice
that I just gave to all of you I very
often will say to him at around 7 p.m.
like I really want to go for a walk
right now you know and I'll go and take
a quiet walk and he's not saying you
know I really wish he'd make dinner or
can I come with you on the walk he knows
I just need the walk and and we build
those kinds of things in and then
there's things that adjustments that I
always have to remember to make for him
and I'll give you an example of one he
has a really lovely delightful way of
getting excited and enthusiastic about
stuff he gets very very exuberant and
it's really nice to be around and so
when my book first hit the bestseller
list
he was like jumping up and down and you
loo lating and you know planning a party
within the first 5 minutes and it was my
book so I was just as excited but my way
of expressing it is much more muted you
know I'm more like this is really great
[Laughter]
so that's fine and I'm really
benefitting from his wonderful
exuberance when I'm around him but what
I always have to remember is and
something great happens for him or for
our family in general I have to give
myself a push to express it in
outward way so that he feels like he's
getting that affirmation back from me
and of course he at the same time needs
to remember that it's never gonna look
the way look to him the way he would
express it but but giving myself that
push can really go a long way so that's
kind of why I was saying before about
why it's so important to make this part
of everyday discourse because there's so
many misunderstandings that can happen
between friends and couples and
colleagues of the kind that I was just
describing like you might think that
someone doesn't care when they really do
care but they just are more muted about
it and and talking about that and making
those tweaks for each other can go such
a long way well I think we might be
almost the end of our time if I'm
looking at it so I want to give some
time for for her to leave on time and
for you to come up and ask questions
individual if you'd like to since we
trying to be supportive of our
introverts so I think what we'll do is
we'll have Stephen come up and close out
the session and give you some sense of
how we're going to move forward but as
he's doing this
I'd love to again thank you very much
for making time to come talk to us we
love the scene the fairy godmother for
for introverts and then we'd love to
have you back on campus as soon as
possible possible so thank you so much
for all your advice oh my gosh
[Applause]
[Music]
okay thank you so much so I want to say
a big thank you to all of you for being
such an incredibly warmly spirited
audience and and if you want to stay in
touch with these questions and these
issues I actually have a website it's
quiet Rev comm for quiet revolution it's
an amazing website there's a lot of
information there's a ton of articles
and ways to connect and so on so I would
invite you there and yeah thank you so
much and thanks to Stephen and to Kim
for doing this right Steve well thank
you so much for joining us today Susan
and taking the time out of your very
busy schedule to be here also Thank You
secretary Gough Cruz for hosting this
conversation and really working with
Yale well to make sure wellness is an
important part of the programming on
campus and also thank you to Yale well
and life lab for sponsoring today's
event the audience thank you so much for
being here and for your engagement and
the insightful questions that you
submitted if you have a lunch ticket if
you could please exit to the left when
you're leaving and go out through old
campus otherwise if you could exit
through the Elm Street door to the right
thank you so much again for Jannetty
wants to just come on up for small
conversations thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]